[Music]
just
imagine you're taking a yoga class right
your instructor's super hot no that's
that's a irrelevant detail right and
then she turns out the lights at the end
of the class gets you into a deep
relaxation mode right has everybody
lying on the floor She Shas this I like
where this is going yeah I do like where
this she's still hot she's still hot
yeah even with the lights off doing
breathing exercises we're at the we're
at the final point of the class again
everybody's lying down releasing all
attention oh yeah eyes closed I would
have farted already letting your body
sink into the mat I like it keep keep
talking like that Nick very motherly
take three counts and just imagine
what's going to happen to the rest of
your day that's how they do that yeah
and then suddenly a mass of police
sirens [__] start blaring right they
pull up good they get swatted they get
swatted everybody runs into this [__]
room the lights are off still yeah yeah
yeah and then busting the door yeah yeah
they're busting all over the place right
what who's busting
where did I miss something where they
finishing I was ripping off him yeah
yeah the point is ejaculate everywhere
okay I think we're taking it too far
apart you said everyone's busting
busting all she's hot there's gay cops
they're seing all over the SE all over
the wall I think I know what's
happenening so gay I was thinking that
they were busting through the doors
exactly see up their pants all right
okay what okay we're back on track we're
back on track they bust in and it's
because somebody called the cops saying
that there was a mass suicide that was
happening in that room that's they
intervene on mass suicide so they
swatted a yoga class yeah because
somebody thought it wasn't yoga funny
you know what it was it was the yoga
studio down the street they're like [__]
those guys dude par power we got it
going down here yo that would be mind
soul yoga dude Anonymous t
at exactly 3:30 at the end of this class
they're going to be in their final phase
of shasa what can the cops do yeah
everyone [__] stop killing yourself
or I'll kill
you everybody lying up we're going to
pump your stomachs what the [__] that's
what I'm saying I'm like what are they
going to do I'll save
you even if it's a if it's a mass
suicide and it already happened they
can't stop it then they still have to
respond to a mass killing right the cops
still got to show up for that they just
have blankets they put over everybody
but then what are they going to do
shouldn't it be like all paramedics or
all firefighters or something all the
chalk outliners don't put that pill in
your mouth or I'll shoot you yeah it's
like you can't do anything what are you
going to do yeah like what the [__]
that's pretty they were responding to a
call from a member of the public worried
there had been a mass killing at the
studio um Millie LW who runs Unity yoga
was teaching the class kind of close of
course it was called that
which also doubles as a community space
in art gallery and they're always a
community space and you got to save
they're not doing yoga they got to do
other things like karate pilat karate
pilat karate Pat
yoga Unity yoga we have it all karate
pilat that's kind of tight though yeah
is dude he's he's built nine businesses
today he's like the daycare the Puppy
Patrol I got karate
mot the Puppy
Patrol I can kind of see it yeah see it
for you yeah they did put out a
statement they said dear general public
after the incident said please be
mindful that the observatory has lots of
yoga classes happening in the evenings
we are not part of any mad cult or
crazy it's adjacent though it's right
there mad cult adjacent you it's all
chill Namaste good down
ground you're already lying on the
ground get on the ground we are we are
roll over roll
over get on the on your bellies I don't
know [__] get in child's pose
[__] that's [__] wild dude that that
would be at least memorable cuz it is
kind of funny they should have thrown
tear gas on those [__]
ID they should have lit him up bean bags
man I would have sued him for blocking
my chakras dude
yeah you guys disrupted my chakra my
chakras dude this guy is in the space he
knows who do you think called who would
it's obviously the down the street yoga
studio dude comp mind soul yoga [__] Pat
studio and they're like Pilates is just
way better get way more benefits yeah
hey Pilates is pretty crazy huh those
like machines look [__] have you guys
done Pilates like in a have you taken a
class dude not it looks like here's the
thing I'm all about like Mas whatever
like to femininity it looks too feminine
like I can't like I can't like be like
serious and be like
you know what I'm talking about like it
looks dude am I wrong it's it's honest
it seems like it's just strength
training but just you know they just
have a routine like it's it's more like
stretchy than anything it's what is it
it's like I heard that [__] is hard as
[__] rose on the training
B you know what he said I didn't say
anything but isn't that more masculine
though cuz you can see all these hot
girls stretching yeah but you're in like
tight pants going like this like the
girls aren't like [__] that's the guy
that's going to save me in the middle of
the night you know what I mean and also
too when you're the only guy in an all
woman's class they all look at you like
you're a [__] creeper regardless if
you are and you're automatically either
friend zone or creep Zone you can't look
at any of them one time because the
second you like make eye contact one
they're like it's uncomfortable and I'm
not saying that's like anyone's fault
but like that's just kind of like men
and women and like people don't want to
be left alone well whose fault is it
though um ladies Adam and Eve dude they
[__] that [__] up they ruined it yeah
they [__] it up for us
I'll stop staying at the back of the
yoga class then he's not even eating
he's like eating a bag of chips he's
like not even doing the yoga yeah he's
in like Street closed he's like he's got
his tripod set up he's just saying yeah
the whole time yeah I'm the videographer
I'm doing this for marketing oh
yeah oh that's nice he's like this is my
business marketing for yoga liveing yog
that's his next business I'm like here
for support have you taken a public
Fitness class before I did yoga I did
Hot Yoga I did I never did Pilates
though yeah look no guys are doing
Pilates on the RS yeah no way bro no way
I like yoga it was pretty cool and then
uh but I don't know I I haven't done any
like group classes like I want to try it
looks fun dude I'd rather do bar before
I do Pilates which bar it's like a
[__] it's almost like a ballet class
oh you hold on to and you like s oh it's
[__] hard dude oh it's like pure the
the one's like pure pure Beret Beret
yeah yeah P yeah yeah that one that one
wow it's spelled it's spelled weird what
about those yeah I had a white
exgirlfriend whatever you how many times
[__] Starbucks and pet I had to be
involved in tired of it how about like a
Taio or like that kind of step class
like isn't that hella old yeah I think
it's like if there a will there's a way
he's like what about
P90X
get with the times Insanity sometimes I
see the the group classes at 24-hour
fitness and I'm like dude that would be
so fun to dress80s and just do it one
day bro they look like they're having a
Blas but you have to take it like super
serious you have to walk in there like
like I'm the Man The Crazy Ones ones
where they wear harnesses and they're
[__] doing like these I've seen those
crazy routines I think you're going to a
different group thing you know what I'm
talking about
bondage they got they're wearing and
they got these bungee cords attached to
the ceiling everybody's in them and then
there's full routines where they're
doing like full
leans n dude he's like they got strap on
you're like dude you're in a different
group thing they got crazy knots and
they tie you like this all right [__]
you guys they oil you up
before you know they got this ball gag
thingy that you put in your mouth and
you bend over and then your Fitness in
structure gives you a anal massage all
right they call it bungee Fitness check
this out sounds whack that sounds like a
scam looks kind of views ridiculous it's
his own channel no one's fitting there
dude I'll tell you do they do this at
commercial gyms or what is this oh dude
what the [__] is that's what you do on
the swings at the park hey man people
just need to go on the treadmill bro
seriously just [__] just just you got
looks a little bit fun for who dude but
how I would have a blast doing that I
mean dude I would throw up it looks
stupid but I I think sometimes looking
stupid is the half of the fun next JK I
can get on board with thator is going to
be like how I got my body views I'm
going to I'm going to come back here in
a year and you guys are all going to be
doing this in
here you're sitting here doing the
videos like
this I feel like most things though it's
because people got [__] Mobility cuz
they haven't got out of their couch in
like 10 years so they have to do
something like normal [__] like I be
seeing some of the stuff that older
folks do at the commercial gym and I'm
like man that just looks like like you
need to move your arms I mean that
lowkey still looks like a lot of
Mobility yeah really fun though just
walk around your neighborhood honestly
just walk just walk just walk why are
you Fitness shaming right now no because
not it's whack that's that's really bad
that's actually really bad for you dude
imagine you need a diarrhea and then the
harness isn't coming off yeah dude
running to you keep getting pulled back
oh godamn or imagine it's like
somebody's first time in that class and
they're just [__] up the whole
routine that is so wack well part of the
reason why people need to work out is
they need to have like weight on their
body right this is doing the complete
opposite well I imagine myself jumping
around like Kung Fu movie I see that as
like a kung fu movie if you're Chun fat
yeah you could do thank God someone said
it okay just kidding I didn't want to be
the one to say
it I was thinking it the whole time like
someone better say it this is Crouching
Tiger oh you say it you say it no dude
no no no no no you guys are going to
clip this up for viws I'm going to be
you know it's going to start with me
holding like the the Japanese tacks I'm
like we can't do that come on to the
next thing is that is that Japanese to
you [__] I knew the second that came out
I was like damn it oh you're telling me
this looks Japanese to you dude this guy
dude we're all the same huh [__] you
guys huh I've been so careful this whole
time
kidding
[Music]
for